اكثر من موعد حددت اوكرانيا لشن هجومها
المضاد لاسترجاع الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها
القوات الروسيه لكن ما سبب التاخير مصادر
عده نجحت ان نقص السلاح هو المعضله لكن
الصحيفه واشنطن تحدثت عن اسباب اخرى
للتاجيل المتكرر الصحيفه نقلت عن خبراء
غربيين مخاوفهم من غياب استعداد كييف
للتعامل مع حجم الصعوبات التي يمثلها
الهجوم المضاد
ذلك الهجوم الذي احاطت كييف مواقعه
بالسريه الا ان محللين عسكريين توقعوا
منطقه زبالوجيا احد تلك المواقع لكن عقبات
عده تكشفت للقياده الاوكرانيه منها ما
صنعتها بنفسها عندما احاطت المنطقه بحقول
من الالغام بمقابلها حسن الجيش الروسي
المنطقه بتحويل مساحات من الحقول الزراعيه
الى قلعه تتضمن خطوطا دفاعيه وخنادق كبيره
وهذه التحصينات الروسيه حذر الخبراء من ان
مواجهتها ستتسبب بحمام من الدماء
واقترحوا ان الخيار الافضل لمواجهتها يكمن
باستخدام دبابات امون ابرامز الامريكيه
التي مدت واشنطن باعداد رمزيه منها
لكن الخبراء شددوا على ان مواجهه تلك
التحصينات الروسيه تتطلب تدريبا دقيقا
للقوات الاوكرانيه وبالطبع الامدادات
العسكريه اللازمه وهنا تكون العقده حيث
واجهت بريطانيا رساله في هذا التوقيت
الحساس مفادها ان الاسلحه الغربيه بدات
تنفذ لدى حلفاء اوكرانيا بحسب وزير الدفاع
البريطاني الذي اكد انها حقيقه واقعيه
الرساله دفعت لطرح تساؤلات تتعلق بتوقيت
الهجوم المضاد في ظل ازمه السلاح
والامدادات حنان المصري العربيه